this is a production of cornell
university
so yeah i'll be talking about cover
cropping rotations for weed seed bank
management
and i guess i should give a little bit
of an intro uh to myself i'm brian brown
and the integrated weed management
specialist the new york state ipm
uh based out of geneva new york
um i cover all different crops uh fruits
vegetables field crops ornamentals and
uh recently added a community or
landscape uh setting so so basically
weeds in any setting is uh what i work
on um
and uh
i guess a
a fair amount of my background is is
related to uh kind of non-chemical
alternative controls
light cover cropping um
as well as cultivation mulching and some
others
um
so
yeah i i definitely view cover crops uh
with
i guess within the context of weed seed
bank management
and
i guess a little bit of background on
weed seed banks because it's kind of a
it can be a foreign term um
so weed seed banks are basically just
the the number and
the different speed the different
species and the number of seeds that are
in your soil or in the soil of a given
field
uh you can see here soil from four
different fields actually four different
farms
and the two on the left were very weedy
and this is this is actually soil
samples that i brought back to the
greenhouse laid out the soil and flats
and
then watered over the course of the
summer to encourage germination
and there's a big range and
in how
uh different different farms are in
different fields are
most of that has to do with
how
how
persistent the the management has been
in not letting weeds go to seed
and that was definitely the case uh in
these examples here the farmers
from the two fields on the left on the
right sorry um
really tried hard to prevent
weeds from setting seed wherever
possible
and so over time the number of seeds in
their soil the weed seed bank
was depleted
um and so so that's kind of a
preventative aspect is is not letting
weeds set seed but you can also do
things to try to remove the seeds from
your soil even if there are already
seeds there and one of the best ways to
do that is through a bare fallow or a
stale seed bed period in which you
really try to encourage
weeds to germinate
so that you can come through and control
them
and that basically just removes all of
those seeds from your soil so
all those seeds would have germinated in
your crop uh you know if if if you
hadn't done this this final pass
of weed control so
um
a single pass like that is sometimes
called a stale seed bed right before you
plant your crop uh your cash crop
or if you're
doing a more extended a longer
period where you may come through a few
different times and
and prep the ground to encourage
germination and then control
any resulting weed seedlings with
tillage or herbicides
then we'll call that a bear fallow
and that's
in my view uh
one of the best ways to
to decrease your weed seed bank
here i have kind of a
put together a bit of a gradient
in some different practices and most of
these are involved in cover crops
but yeah on the far right side of the
screen there and looking at
ways to decrease the weed seed bank
i think probably a bear fallow is is
probably going to be one of the most
effective ways
because the ground is bare
most of our our problems species
like bare ground that can kind of
stimulate germination through
the sunlight hitting the soil
some some of that sunlight will actually
reach the seed and tell them that it's
okay it's time to germinate
um
and also that sunlight will will heat up
the soil and it will heat up during the
day and it will cool down at night and
the seeds can sense that amplitude that
difference between day and night and
they say okay it's there must be bare
soil
it's time for us to germinate um
so
you know so when the soil is bare i
think you tend to get a lot of of
germination um
and then on the other end of the the
spectrum here
of course no management if if you've got
uh just a weedy mess
and all those
those weeds are growing up four or five
six feet tall and producing thousands of
seeds per plant
of course that's going to add to your to
your seed bank
um but also cover crops you know if if
you have a a cover crop that does not
establish successfully
and and you're you just have to leave it
for the whole season for whatever reason
there's going to be weeds in there and
they're probably going to
out compete in areas anyway and patches
out compete and grow over top of the
cover crop and produce a lot of seeds
so even if you have a cover crop
you may it's it's not a done deal you
can still be contributing to your weed
seed bank
um and then next over in the line
a nearly weed-free
a long season cover crop so you know
full a full summer
is one that that has the potential to
add a few weed seeds to your soil and
it's it's not gonna um it's not gonna
probably add significant numbers of seed
if it's a successful
cover crop um it's gonna hopefully do a
good job suppressing most of the weeds
but because it's a long season cover
crop if you're just putting something in
for the whole summer
then because you have that long period
with no management there's a lot of weed
species that have the ability to set
seed
within that period so even if they're
small they may contribute to the seed
bank to some extent
so for that reason i i have actually
the most
effective in my view
way to use cover crops to deplete the
weed seed bank
is is kind of a mix it's kind of using
cover crops in between
tillage or or herbicide
applications
and these kind of rapid fire cover crops
never let
never i guess allow enough time
for weeds to set seed and so any weeds
that that do come up with the cover crop
and inevitably there will be
some or potentially many
uh
you're going to terminate them before
they set seats or you're effectively
taking them out of production
and
yeah so this this highlights the example
of
weeds in your cover crops that you may
not know they're there you know this is
a
from afar and even actually from a
pretty up close view this looks like a
very successful stand of buckwheat
and and it is
but um you know there will always likely
be some weeds this is pulling apart that
canopy
and you can see some some pigweed and
some some common chickweed down there uh
maybe some some others
and yeah these these aren't anywhere
near setting seed at this point but it's
important to scout and and and you know
not just
drive by the cover crops
but actually take a look at what's going
on
under that canopy because
you know sometimes
and this is a different field sometimes
there are
weeds that are flowering and about to
set seed and uh you know in in a weed
seed bank context you really
want to try to terminate the cover crop
before
these swedes set seed
okay so yeah you you may be looking at
this little gallon soga and think well
okay there's just one little flower on
that planet there's one little flower in
the next plant and yeah i mean they
they're not going to produce you know
these little seeds these little plants
that are under the crop canopy they're
not going to produce you know a whole
lot of seed
but the question is how much are they
going to produce and how um how what you
know what the longevity of that seed
will be and and how long you'll be
dealing with it in your soil
um so for example
for waterhemp common water hemp tall
water hemp um which we have in new york
which is becoming more problematic
is um a very
becomed species it produces a lot of
seeds
and up to 500 000
and so because it produces so many seeds
and i i actually made a model here
looking at um
what happens to that seed in the soil
and and how many
how many waterhemp plants are going to
be emerging
per acre over time
and um in the in the first half of this
graph the gray area
is with no management so assuming that
that you're not controlling the
waterhemp in in years one two three
up tier four
um and there's that kind of exponential
increase as
the population builds and that that
third year really put on a lot of seed
and then
the transition from the gray to the
white is where i i start the simulation
of
what percent control are you achieving
the water hemp for a year and i actually
did this for for herbicides but it
applies to to cover crops as well if
what percent control are you achieving
with the cover crop you know if you're
only
in this case if you're only reducing the
amount of seed that that the water hemp
is able to produce by 95 percent
then that's actually going to result in
an increase in your weed seed bank
as shown by the the top the dotted line
there
if you're able to
uh control about
98 of the water hemp then you kind of
stay at about a stasis or a stagnant
level there not really increasing or
decreasing
but to really
to really make some gains and and
benefit from
um
the the water hemp that is naturally
going to
die in the soil which is about half of
it every year dies just
on its own and then uh another good
chunk of it germinates and if so if
you're able to kill
all of those you're really removing a
lot of that seed from your soil and so
that that bottom line the black line is
if you're able to control 100 of it
which would be
in the scenario of a cover crop that
you're terminating
before any any seeds are produced
then you can really draw down your weed
seed bank you can really decrease the
number of seeds in your soil
okay um and so
let's see
the the species now this is waterhemp
and um you know this
it does vary by species how many seeds
are produced
and and how long the seeds live in the
soil but species also differ
by when they emerge out of the ground
and that that can actually um be
something that you can help
uh guide your your management and in
your cover cropping uh this is a graph
of some work um
done uh in uh in the midwest
and um yeah we have a lot of these weed
species and and certainly
uh common ragweed is is in common lamb's
quarters some of our earliest emerging
weeds
um
and
you can use this so you know
here i have three different bars a b and
c
uh
representing weeds you know say your
problem weeds emerge in uh you know
april or may is common in these parts
for summer annual weeds
you can use this to to adjust your
management to you know think about which
crops you could use or can you shift the
planting of your crops
to completely avoid
that problem species
and
you know in this case i have i have our
cash crops here
but this could also work for cover crops
or
or you could place a cover crop
um in this in this short period in
looking at a
you could
place a cover crop in that period before
planting your crop to to
just have something
uh you know covering the ground and
producing all those favorable effects
that we like from cover crops before you
plant your your cash crop
just as a means of of delaying
um while you're waiting for this uh this
problem weed to emerge out of the ground
so you can come through and
and control it before planting
some of our weeds emerge mid-summer not
quite as many in the b column but it's
something to consider you can you can
look at these other shorter term crops
or or cereals um to potentially avoid
this this section of weeds
and then c these are these are mostly
winter annuals uh down here in the
bottom uh some perennials
uh or biennials but um
yeah and to avoid those you can maybe
try to plant a little bit earlier in the
spring so the crop is is well
established uh and and will be harvested
um before those those weeds emerge
looking at this a little bit differently
here um and and i should have explained
that that the uh the kind of the dotted
area is the timing of of the weed
emergence
uh the x's are are either a tillage or a
burn down herbicide application
and then the the triangles with the the
vertical bars
represent the crop maturity
um and these are kind of the options for
for avoiding problem timings uh for
weeds you can you can delay here on the
top you're delaying the crop so that you
can come through and tail or spray
and avoid a lot of that germination
second one down you can plant earlier to
try to get a head start on the
competition and get your crop up above
it
especially if it's an early planted crop
compared to the timing of wheat
emergence
but these these these down here on the
bottom i think are are even more
effective so if you've got a period here
um
where the three x's are you know if you
can completely
avoid that period i mean it's it's hard
it may be right in the middle of the
season so you're not going to do it
every year but you know once in a while
if you can set aside a month or two
months and
have a bear fallow in that period you
can
really target the seed bank effectively
um
and the next one down just represents
you know you could put a cover crop in
that period instead you know instead of
all the the bare soil and you know
potential for erosion and runoff
having a cover crop could establish a
similar goal as long as it's terminated
effectively
at the end of that period
and then down in the bottom some of you
may say
hey you know i've got weeds that are
kind of they're coming up year-round
um what should i do and and you know
i've got a situation here where
you know if you're able to take a full
year off
um you know you could potentially put in
a rapid fire sequence of cover crops
followed by termination
that doesn't let any weed produce seeds
um
and i have them kind of spaced
equidistant from each other here
um
but that might not be the best
case as i'll show you uh you know most
of our summer annuals
here i have a little drawing from my my
notebook sometimes i like to do some
things on with pen and paper
um
yeah a lot of our summer annuals emerge
in
may or so and they'll run through the
fall
producing a lot of seed like you see in
the picture here
and
seed set and flowering starts usually in
august
so if you were able to
go drop down to the next uh
the next graph there
that's um
you know say you you till or you spray
in in mid-august to kill all those
initial weeds well there may be a new
batch of summer annuals that you know
probably fewer because they don't have
that same drive to
emerge um
later on in the summer
but there will probably be few and um
and they will also um
go forth and try to set seed here
um
relatively
rapidly since since fall is on the way
and the days are getting shorter they
can sense that
so
you come through and you and you
tailor you spray but right before that
happens and you drop down to the third
one down
and then well okay then there's these
puny little summer annuals like like
i've got this picture of the common land
supporters here
some of you have probably seen this
where
it's you know it's september or it's
october and you've got these little
seedlings that are putting on
seed because
you know they can sense that that that
the days are getting shorter winter is
coming
um and so
the time that you have to react
uh decreases as you go through the
season
uh 50 i think okay so i'm actually i'm
actually running out of time
um but but i guess my main point with
this is that if if you're able to
go for a full year of cover crops um
it might look something like this where
you have a longer cover crop early on
when those summer annuals
um you know aren't going to be putting
on seed and it gets kind of shorter and
shorter that you have time to work with
going forward
thank you very much
all right happy to talk here so
uh and thanks brian for a very good lead
into what i'm interested in talking
about here
so in using cover crops there's a lot of
different things that
you have to think about
to get everything to work together
timing seeds species all kinds of
different things and i want to
talk about a mnemonic that's helpful
something that
should be pretty easy to remember
and if you remember these seven words
you know all the other things that it
takes
to get a successful cover crop going so
click on the right screen here there we
go and here they are your keys to
success with cover crops number one a
fast start number two no gaps and number
three kill on time so there's there they
are
um
so let me illustrate how you might use
those seven words
so let's start with a fast start
so here's an example of how to get a
fast start this is buckwheat which is
famous for
a fast start so with this one
at four days we have green line
at three weeks full cover of the ground
so
brian was talking about how important it
is to smother those weeds right away
this is why you need a fast start
in fact i thought he had a great example
there of the weeds showing up
that is if your buckwheat takes five or
six days to greenline you will have
weeds germinating underneath them just
like in that picture
and if they're up in four days
you won't
it makes that much difference fast start
really really important
here's an example of
buckwheat that went in the ground but it
was a little too cold and
it's coming up nicely it looks good but
you look in between the rows of
buckwheat and lo and behold
there are other things it wasn't fast
enough
so this
um
from a from a weed suppression
standpoint
um this is a failed stand of buckwheat
already
less than a week
um
and here's another another example where
the weed has a head start on our
crucifer cover crop
so that is another example where it's
not fast enough in this case the weed is
growing fast because it didn't die
completely um but nevertheless that that
weed is going to do just fine so if weed
suppression is the story um getting the
cover crop up faster
uh is critical
so how do you do that so this is where
so i hope i've convinced you you need a
really fast start so all the things that
get a seed out of the ground fast is
what you need so for one you need
quality seed high quality seed is so
much better
than bad seed it's a huge difference and
when you're planting vegetables you pay
a lot of attention to that you don't
want a poor seed lot
you want a variety that has naturally
good vigor so that you get a good stand
same thing with the cover crop
so carryover seed can be a lot weaker
seed that hasn't been stored well
some
seed
producers you can tell often by the the
tag the germ
um whether it's a good seed lot or not
um so watch that get good seed pays off
seed soil contact again this is basics
of planting but
because you're usually trying to do the
least amount of tillage before putting
the cover crop in
you want to then combine that
with
the minimum it takes to get good seed
soil contact so the crumbly soil right
around the the seeds
the shallower they are the faster they
come up not very complicated there
warmer the soil the faster they come up
they need some moisture planting shallow
into dry soil obviously doesn't work
planting into the warm surface but not
being able to close the seed flow
doesn't work you need all of those
things
and you also need to have no live weeds
so the example i showed before this guy
where there was a live weed there you
don't want any of those they should all
be dead dead dead when you plant your
cover crop
um and in that case it was alive but it
was under the ground so we couldn't see
it
um but you know how that works so these
are all things that
really are
more or less second nature to most
growers and you just have to apply them
with the cover crop to get a good fast
start
next up no gaps
so
i think brian showed some good examples
of this too here's a buckwheat stand
where we left um basically one row
unplanted so that we could keep our
plots separate
and um
the weeds are bigger than the buckwheat
so the buckwheat grows well the weeds
grow even better
um that's not a very big gap and you can
see that the weeds start growing
right next to the buckwheat so we find
with buckwheat as an example um six inch
row really good seven inch row works
well eight inch row you start getting
weeds so it's right in there around
eight inches
um
that is the the maximum distance between
plants that you can have in a buckwheat
stand and so there's
the gaps really matter those weeds that
you see in this picture they are
cranking out the weeds so if you're
trying to suppress weeds uh gaps like
that
are completely unacceptable
and
you know they've
they happen
uh for a variety of reasons
so you need to have a seed bed that's
favorable everywhere
and you know you can have wet spots and
knolls and
um
chunks of crop residue all kinds of
things that will create little spots
where the seedbed isn't good and your
cover crop will not come up fast or
won't come up at all and you'll get
weeds instead and then you have weed
seed production
getting uniform seed distribution is
also important it's relatively common
to broadcast cover crop seeds and
in that case
you know if there's a breeze blowing you
might get strips that are unplanted um
if it's not throwing the weed the seeds
very uniformly
really going over a couple of times in
opposite directions those are techniques
you probably know pretty well by now
but it's really worth it to avoid having
those gaps
and then finally having a uniform seed
depth
um so that they all come up fast right
if the seeds are deeper
uh or if there are spots where the seeds
go deeper they don't
grow well if they're not if they're too
shallow in spots um
and
you know we've with the drills we've had
we're just
one of the
the drills was not going in the ground
well
and uh lo and behold there's a row of
weeds right there instead
so those are all familiar things from
crops that really apply to the cover
crops
and then i want to finish up
with the kill on time
and
what is on time so this one really
matters a lot
there's a lot of
different things you're thinking about
in terms of what you're trying to get
out of your cover crop
so one
fairly common one is to get the right
carbon nitrogen ratio if you're growing
for
nitrogen purposes you want a low carbon
nitrogen ratio you want a nice lush
green
mostly succulent lush leaves that's what
you want you don't want something that's
more mature than that
but if you're trying to have long
lasting organic matter then you want a
high carbon nitrogen ratio
and related to that getting the right
durability
if you want it
to be lignified and fibrous and last for
a long time
then you want to be at one end
if you want it to
be broken down fairly quickly then you
want little lignin and fiber development
i'm looking forward to jean paul's talk
on that particular point um
you need time to decompose before the
next crop it's not that long depends on
the season how long it's going to be but
then
and then the nature of what you're
tilling in and what kind of seed bed
you're going to need for for planting
your crop so you need to think about
that interval
the flowering of the cover crop is
important
with
most cover crop species that's when
they're easiest to kill so that's uh
one aspect which is my next point uh but
it's also you don't want weeds you don't
want volunteer seats in the cover crop
so the cover crop needs to not make
seeds that's
really important for success because
they can be perfectly good weed some of
them are very effective weeds if you
let them compete with your crop
but the susceptibility to the killing
method so
it depends i mean there's lots of ways
to kill cover crops whichever one you're
using you want the growth stage of the
cover crop to be
appropriate for that killing method we
have
um
an example some of the spring
[Music]
grains
are typically filled with glyphosate but
it has to be warm for glyphosate to work
so
and the spring isn't necessarily warm so
you have to wait until they're
susceptible in order for that to work so
there's
timing issues like that
then often if you're trying to build
biomass you need enough of that there's
a whole bunch of other management
constraints
but
knowing what it is you're trying to do
and when you need to kill it so i'll
show some examples so here is uh this is
actually triticale but it
looks very similar to rye
and for planting a
direct seeded vegetable
with the winter cover crop if you have
it on for winter protection so the
maturity at the left
is really a good killing time
that gives you succulent green material
that breaks down easily you can produce
a good seed bed you have enough time for
it to break down if you let it wait a
little bit longer
and in this case it's a couple of weeks
but if if you go to um the maturity on
the
right side there um now you've got a lot
more lignified material it doesn't break
down very quickly um
it will
leave enough residue to interfere with
planting and it's not going to decompose
very well and this is
uh what it can look like so
at first glance it seems like those beds
are all the same
but the ones that were killed at green
up on the 24th of april is the left half
and there you see the beds are forming
pretty nicely
and there is very little residue so
we'll plant into those easily
on the right there
you see that there's some straw on top
and we're really having a lot of trouble
getting the edges of the beds forming
right because of the crowns of the rye
and so these were not covered with
plastic but if they if you were trying
to cover these with plastic that plastic
would not stretch over the bed very well
um
it would be pretty uneven and you really
want to get that plastic taut that would
be tough to do on the beds that were
killed at 10 inches so
thinking about that timing
for various management purposes is
really
going to be important and those stems
grow fast i just
zoomed in on this one so there's the
stem starting to grow it's only a couple
of inches tall
at this point
um
but
in the springtime it zooms and your
opportunities to get in there and kill
it are often limited
so you need to be ready
here's an example of
forage rapeseed we want this one to
winter kill
but they it was so on the left is what
it looks like in the fall
um
and some of them had started to bolt
which makes them susceptible to the
frost but some of them hadn't there were
some runty ones in the stand and the
runty ones
were still rosettes so they survived the
winter
and so in the springtime this is what it
looked like
um
they're going to seed there's not enough
of them there to be useful as a cover
crop it's not going to make any biomass
the stand is not big enough to really
suppress the spring weeds
i see some chickweed in there even
and it may even go to seed before it's
dry enough for you to go in there and
kill it so don't
you don't want that uh so here's here's
what we do want with a winter killed
uh
crucifer so this is good old tillage
radish
and uh they're dead dead dead uh in the
springtime here very reliably
the downside is that they they actually
die too early
for recovering the nitrogen that
nitrogen pretty much leaks out of them
by march this time of year
so it's difficult to to recycle the
nitrogen from the spring with these so
that's another aspect where having them
die this time of year is
better so some of the turnips will do
that for us
then another one you want to avoid the
regrowth and the volunteer scene so here
we're terminating a buckwheat stand with
mowing so mowing is the least effective
way to kill it but it works
and it um
so we're using that to really look at
the the sensitivity here and so on the
left we mowed after 30 days sooner than
you would typically want to
mow 35 is really where you want to be
and so the lower nodes can still regrow
and so here this is
about a month and a half later that this
is going into the fall
they've got seeds on them they've got
lots of seeds on them probably
enough to do a whole other wonderful
stand of buckwheat the following spring
you don't want that
if you wait too long
they will
go to seed and what we see when they
were mowed at 45 days there's actually
fruit that are far enough along that
they will mature and so there are
quite a few buckwheat seedlings already
germinating in the fall and there will
be more in the springtime so that's not
good either and at the bottom you can
see a little bit of a plant that was uh
flattened by the mower so it's
even though it's been horizontal now for
uh quite a while it's still making seeds
on that plant also
so you want to get it when it's
susceptible to being killed
not when it's going to regrow and not
when it has already put
viable seed on
so with buckwheat i should say when is
it time to do that you can put it on
your calendar 35 days after planting um
buckwheat also gives you a single what's
the difference between the field on the
left and the field on the right can you
detect the subtle difference there that
is the buckwheat telling you time to get
out there and kill it
not too complicated
um
so i'll just repeat
how do you get a fast start
how do you avoid gaps in the stand
and how do you kill on time so
so you have to know your goal
you have to
have the
right termination method suited to the
gold and finally
when you plant your cover crop you have
to know how and when it's going to die
so that sounds simple it really goes
against the grain of most people when
they're planting is they're not thinking
about killing they're thinking about
growing but uh know how and when
it's going to die that will be the
way to have the most success
so i'm going to
leave that slide up for my
finale here and see if we have any
questions on this one thank you brian
and thank you thomas
those were two fairly great
presentations um
and uh i hope to be able to build on uh
a lot of uh
the things that you already shared
so regarding crotalaria or sun hemp
and building over thomas said what are
your goals well the goals
why i ever started growing crotalia or
sun hem
was to have a cover crop that could um
build long-term soil health um because
quote layer or as many people call it
sun hemp uh it implies in the name
it was used actually as a
crop to make into rope has a lot of
lignin so the idea that you can grow a
cover crop
that both fixes nitrogen it's a legume
and also build long-term soil health was
very intriguing to me
the question was can we can we grow it
it's mostly a southern crop it's a it's
a tropical crop so it depends on where
you are located if you actually can be
successful in growing it
but i was intrigued and so
over the years i've been growing it on a
smaller and on a larger scale
and i will be sharing with you
what i've done so first of all how does
it fit in the rotation and and the and
how it fits in rotation is because it
needs um
warmth to germinate
um
it fits after early vegetables so these
are early greens
a top shot or it fits right after
a crop a winter cover crop of rye
and then the question is
for the grower do i want to harvest the
rye
there is time to harvest the rye not
maybe for seed but for straw in this
particular case it's cut when it is in
full flower
or
for some growers that would like to not
harvest the rye
you can cut it a few times
until it is terminated
and then work that under
we've tried planting quote layer
directly after
the stubble
of the rye
it's no-till with little success um we
actually introduced a
small bear fallow period
right after the rye
and had better success um with um
germination
um
so here's an example um actually there's
some of the uh um
uh
other seeds that were mixed in here is
um
uh
red eye peas
i have done a lot of different mixes
over the years i've made a lot of
mistakes over the years especially
mixing in too much sorghum
and what are the problems with growing
crotalaria is that it takes a long time
and um as um was pointed out in the
previous presentation one of the things
is you want to a fastest establishment
so the other seats don't come up and
when you do crotalaria 100 crotalaria
the likelihood that other seeds will
germinate as well
um
is very high
so
what are you going to
be using as a complementary to the
crotalaria
to make sure that there is enough shade
and enough ground cover
so the other weeds don't have a chance
and i've tried
millet i've tried um sorghum
and
red eyed peas
and also sunflowers and what i actually
came up with that a mix of 60 pounds of
crotalaria
5 pounds of sunflowers and 20 pounds of
sorghum
um even 10 pounds of sorghum might be
enough so the question knows also to the
grower
what kind of wheat pressure do you have
what kind of a wheat seed bank do you
have and the more of a wheat pressure
you have i would say the higher amounts
you would want
of the sorghum and the sunflowers
the sunflowers and the
sorghum establish very quickly
and again i cannot emphasize enough that
you do want your soil to be
above
20
about 60 degrees
so
here is um
after a couple of weeks you can see the
sunflowers in this field um you actually
don't see the crotalaria in this field
at all it seems like it's all sorghum
and it's all sunflowers at that stage of
the game this is probably the beginning
of august
even a little bit later you can see here
i can maybe point my here is some
crotalaria
it's lurking underneath
now if you have a good establishment
there are very few weeds underneath here
and the reason why is because we use
shade
as a means to
repress any kind of development of weeds
underneath
and um as you know that most of the
summerweeds uh are able to establish
them very very um
large and easily like when we talk about
lamb's quarter or um uh
red rooted amaranth
um so i think these are the kind of
things whereby uh
um
you need to make sure that you
have uh
uh
have that early establishment
so you don't see these weeds peaking up
there
later on um
the the crotalites start growing and now
the sunflowers are in full flower which
also actually makes for a very nice and
colorful cover crop the birds really
enjoy
going to a cover crop like this this
actually slide
this tractor is
at the same height as the cover crop so
this is a very tall cover crop it's a
way to
bring a lot of
organic matter into your soil
now here we see a september picture
now we see the sorghum kind of like
dying down the sunflowers are hardly
visible and now the crotalia really
um it comes into flower
and uh
and and it's almost like a surprise how
it
um emerges out of the cover crop itself
now the next question of course that uh
that thomas already framed how are we
going to terminate it
well you can break your mower trying to
mow that down
and we are not going to try to mode it
down until the frost has killed the
entirety of this crop
and the reason
why we don't break our mower when we
wait until after a good killing frost is
because we have removed the water out of
the crotal area and out of the sorghum
and the sunflower
uh allowing us to much easier modis crop
or this or to actually
turn it into smaller pieces
we're not going to try to
till this into the ground it's just too
much work um
it is it really doesn't help much
to try to do this so we leave this as a
ground cover as a mulch over the winter
when we come back in the spring and the
snow has melted this is what we're
finding
a very relatively dense cover
of stocks
a lot of lignin as you can see and even
then it's going to be
difficult to imagine planting a
vegetable directly into this ground
again we won't do that
we will just try to
borrow somebody's no-till drill
and try to drill piece
directly into that
um
if you
have a problem with termination
of um your cover crop then i would say
you stick with uh strictly peas and you
don't mix in the oats
mixing the oats again gives you um
a little better
competition with any kind of weeds that
might emerge
uh
in that um
spring grounds
um but that's what we do then
and we're planting that directly
in there
and then through the malts
the oats and peas will emerge
i've also done some experiments with
mixing in bell beans uh
if it wasn't for the cost of bell beans
i really enjoy growing the bell beans in
there
bell beans are not very good at
suppressing weeds the peas and the oats
are much better at doing that
and they are they quickly emerge but i
do like the ground that the bell beans
leave
and here again we see this what that
looks like
and all for time
and it grows up and there's really no
weeds there
and then when it is time we mow the oats
and peas down and incorporate that
and then of course we're all way by the
beginning of june so
we
we have already missed the window to
plant early
vegetable crops and what is really
surprising about
planting the oats and peas and working
them under when they're relatively
succulent still
they're just about to go into flour
is that
for some reason that i cannot explain
most of the
material
that is underneath the oats and peas
uh has disappeared um you look
underneath there and all the
the remnants of the crotalaria and the
sorakum and the sunflower
have been absorbed by the microorganism
in the soil they found a very
wonderful environment living
underneath the cover of the oats and
peas
and
decomposed most of these
very lignacious um
cover and then we're following that with
say a crop of all
um
brassicas which could be fall broccoli
could be cabbage could be cauliflower
and what is interesting about this is
that we had one time
the graduate students of dr laurie
drinkwater come out and
measure the biomass that
was
developed after the oats and peas and
about between 150 to 200 pounds of
nitrogen
was turned into the soil
um
and this is also speaks to our
experience is that when we
make sure that
we do this all correctly
we actually don't apply fertilizer
on a crop
like broccoli or cabbage or cauliflower
it is not we don't need it after a
rotation like that one of the things
that i will say about
doing this successfully is that
um
i cannot emphasize some of the points
that have already been made in the
previous presentations
that you do need to
make sure that the trotillaria
uh
is uh
drilled correctly in the soil but also
that you you know the point i want to
add to that
at the right temperature but also that
you are testing your soil to make sure
that it is in optimum condition
so we're actually looking at
making sure that our soil is already in
optimum condition even for broccoli in
the previous year
um
and so
when we apply any nutrients as needed uh
we can actually do that directly after
uh or or before the in after the
incorporation of ryer before the
incorporation of rye or
we've done that before the planting of
the spring vegetables so we are looking
at our
nutrients requirements uh way before
then and of course they're being
recycled in the soil but not removing
anything and they then continue to be
available
for
now when we want to follow that with
another crop we can follow
after this after a bear fallow as
as brian pointed out they have an
additional bear fellow there we follow
it a crop of buckwheat
and then in the fall we plant garlic so
there's a number of different options
so here as summary
year spring we can do the rye
early leafy greens followed by
a short bear fallow
drilling of protelaria mix
late fall
and we're talking here really about
november
the mowing of the crotalaria
year two drilling of the oats and peas
year two summer incorporation of peas
and bear fellow
followed by fall brassica or
alternatively followed by buckwheat
to again you know to really flush out
your
um
your your the weeds in in this this
wheat seed bank
and then after the incorporation of
buckwheat you can follow that then with
a late plant of the crop of garlic in
september
and
if there's any questions
i think i have time for that
great yep a few minutes for questions
nice job really cool
uh steve asks
uh do you need a specific inoculant soil
inoculant for the sunhem yeah you do
actually um now i forget which one it is
um and
thank you for mentioning that that is
very very important that you do have the
right uh inoculant
in order for um both piece
and uh the quota layout to work but so
talk to your supplier and make sure that
they're supplying you with the correct
inoculant
and and john paula are you
happy with this with the crotal area are
you going to continue with it or is it
too
challenging
no i mean as long as you have the
equipment uh
to mow it
um and um we have not done it for i i
did not when i moved to philly farm um i
left the no-till drill at roxbury
and now um we are able usd i was able to
buy a no-till drill so now we can again
incorporate that so
having access to that is is really
important so i also encourage growers to
contact the local usda office and see if
they can apply for a grant to obtain a
no-till drill
to be able to
you know bear fellow is really important
brian
but sometimes you would you want to be
able to plant a crop
without tilling
absolutely yep
fantastic all right well great uh well
thank you john paul and i'll switch over
thanks
for the invitation to be here today
brian and it's an honor to be
uh one of a number of speakers here that
uh i would say know much more about
cover crops than i do
i'm gonna share some of my experience
with cover crops specifically in plastic
culture vegetables so vegetables that
are grown on plastic mulch that could
include biodegradable mulch
and oftentimes in these settings we call
that cover crop a living mulch so
sometimes we might say cover crop
sometimes we say might say living mulch
um it means the same thing in this
context
and i'm not going to be able to stick
around for our final speaker uh today i
did review thierry's uh
presentation
so
you have the opportunity as the audience
to kind of compare and contrast um
two separate experiences with this
approach to
using cover crops and vegetables or in
plastic vegetables
so
let's start with the why of
using living mulch why would you do this
this is
hopefully a video that you're going to
be able to see
of onion harvest in the alba area of new
york state
if the video loads
and
while we wait for that to load
i want you to try to look at that
that field there's almost no onions in
that field we're going to skip this
excuse me almost no wheeze in that field
the reason being when you have a large
field
of onions without any plastic mulch you
do have a number of herbicide options
that are quite effective
those herbicides really even on a
conventional
small scale vegetable farm
aren't a commonly used tool
because they're specific to onions and
don't have a lot of other applications
they're very expensive
the herbicides also when they're used in
plastic culture situations
may damage our crop
here you can see some onions grown on
silver and plastic mulch there was an
herbicide used here you can see it did a
great job at controlling those weeds now
when the farmer went through to pull
these onions
all they got was a handful of tops
because the bulbs stayed
in the ground because of misapplication
of herbicide
now another reason to think about living
mulch instead of herbicides
this is a bicycle in my uh my home
county of yates county
and this is uh
a jug of herbicide
being carried ironically by a little
debbie um
snacks
cardboard box
now what happens to that bicyclist
if he or she wipes out and that
herbicide spills all over them and all
over the road
what if that
herbicide was something that was very
toxic
so just a few thoughts
so what we decided to do was look at a
way to grow cover crops because of these
reasons i just shared between
our beds of plastic mulch we're somewhat
addicted to plastic because of the weed
control and the moisture retention that
it provides right on the row the
additional
soil heating
but wanted to get away from those
herbicides so we initially began working
with rye cereal rye and i know that our
next speaker will also mention this
why are we using rye rye is an
outstanding competitor it's an
inexpensive seed
and if we sow that
as a living mulch in the spring it won't
form a seed head it needs a winter time
to trigger that
seed production so it stays vegetative
and is an outstanding competitor
so let's see
our initial seeding date in our research
was april 10th
and our initial crop that we were
looking at was sweet onions so large
bulb onions
unfortunately in our first year research
we
then had maybe three or four inches of
snow and freezing temperature
and the weeds or the wheat the rye seed
interpreted that as winter and so it
produced a seed head so there is a risk
here
that this will go to seed and then you
have a field like this which is a mess
some farmers responded to that by using
herbicides to control the rye for living
mulch between those beds of onions
specifically around them that is a legal
use and
our following speaker will go into
greater detail on the use of herbicides
to control
living mulch but we weren't looking to
kill our cover crop for our living mulch
we wanted to keep it alive and this is
what it might look like in an ideal
situation this is just simply cereal rye
we
lay our beds of plastic and before we
transplant or make any transplant holes
in this case for tomatoes we want to
scatter or broadcast that rye over top
of the entire field
and then if we need to maybe we're going
to sweep off that plastic maybe the
wind's going to take that seed off that
plastic but we don't want the cover crop
seed getting into our transplant holds
where it becomes another weed for us
as you can see rye is an outstanding
competitor and one of the research
questions is does it compete with our
vegetable crop and here you see a living
mulch of rye between rows of tomatoes
really this is a rye field with a few
tomatoes in the on plastic beds
what we found was that in a
wet spring that rye will indeed stay
vegetative but it will grow quite a bit
to the point where we need to manage it
or mow it
so
initially we thought we might reduce
labor if we were to compare the living
mulch to say cultivation or that
cultivation is with horses or a tractor
or by hand
but in reality there's probably not a
labor reduction or at least not a time
reduction because we need to mow this
rye particularly in a wet spring
you also then have an issue of when you
mow that however you mow it with a
line trimmer or a riding mower can you
keep those rye clippings from off of a
fruiting vegetable say tomatoes and
peppers you can have a contamination
problem
over time we also found that even though
the rye stayed vegetative
it would eventually succumb to a disease
called rust and foot traffic
and you can see that going on here with
tomatoes
so let's see this is looking at
i can't even see what it's looking at i
think we're looking at one square feet
of row middle and is it weight of weeds
and you can see that rye compared to our
cultivation and herbicide plots was
providing very good weed control
that rye though was apparently causing
some competition with our onions that
resulted in
taller onions compared to cultivation or
herbicide treatments
unfortunately
boy this is frustrating i can't see my
slide titles
thrips
um we didn't really see any difference
in thrips a common pest of onions
between these different treatments
now let's talk about really what matters
yield
and unfortunately we did see a major
yield decrease where we had living mulch
compared to our cultivation and
herbicide treatments
in this case we're looking at
yield
in pounds per 10 feet of bed and you see
we were losing close to 20 pounds of
onions over those
10 feet why is that
the cultivation and herbicide treatments
compared to a living mulch
had more colossal a colossal onion is a
size
grade so it's greater than four inch
diameter bulb we're getting more
colossals and more jumbos
in our cultivation and herbicide
treatments than rye
so why is that that's a question
that remains to be answered but i
imagine a lot of it is competition for
water and competition for nutrients
so we noticed that farmers were toying
with other species of living mulches one
of those being clover looks like a type
of red clover between rows of tomato
plants
so we began to incorporate clover
into our research on
cereal rye as a as a living mulch this
is our seeding rate we're looking around
150
pounds of
rye or grain to
15 to 20 pounds of clover
and we also began including barley in
our work
we lay out our plots again and one of
the things we found was that living
mulches
do exceedingly well where we're using
row cover for temperature protection
spring or pest protection in the spring
and it might do a little bit too well
and so in this case that living mulch
was growing and competing with our
pepper crop
and we were unable to mow it because it
was underneath that cover
so this is cumulative weed biomass on a
square foot basis
and what you'll see here is that the
plots that included both a winter grain
such as rye or barley in combination
with clover had the least amount of
weeds
compared to winter grain alone or
compared to cultivation which we all
know is never perfect so this was a
positive result for us incorporating
clover into the living mulch over time
unfortunately where we had more living
mulch we were still seeing a yield loss
on a
row foot basis where we had that clover
treatment
a quick um anecdotal experience i'll
share when using a living mulch is that
its effectiveness in controlling weeds
depends
um not just on the principles that that
thomas shared with us earlier which are
outstanding but also on your weed
species so here's one of our cooperating
farms in the hudson valley that was
growing peppers and their primary wheat
species was crab grass
and crab grass competes just fine
because it can be mowed
or it can grow underneath
a living mulch and then spread out and
produce a seed head on plastic so if
grasses are your primary weed species
this may not be the best weed control
technique
now that ground cover over time this is
where the clover really began to shine
so you can see
the
red bar portion of the bar here is our
cover crop or living mulch the blue
portion is the weeds
and this is in june 12th
moving forward
to
about a month later july
you can see that the rye clover in
particular
the row middle is almost all cover crop
very little weed
so that was providing outstanding weed
control for us and over time that
continued to be one of our better
treatments
here we are in september so if we want
long-term
weed suppression using a living mulch
the clover has greater longevity than
the rye or the barley alone
the rye and barley however
allow that clover to have a good start
it really promotes its germination in
early growth so that combination is
probably the best in our treatments
i'm just checking my time
so
when it comes to cover cropping um it's
a bit of an art and science and i'd like
to say that
um this picture is really a work of art
you can see some buckwheat here in the
background that uh thomas would tell us
it is time to control that it's in
flower attracting a bunch of wonderful
beneficials and pollinators
over here to the left we've got some
sort of
um
uh vegetative it looks like a grain
and then in the row middles here
the farmer is growing a veg um i think
this is either hairy or purple veg
and then
we have these um
peppers on bare ground in the center of
all those cover crops
this is indeed a work of art however we
are not in the art business we're in the
vegetable business
so my message is cover crops can indeed
be
competition for our vegetable crop and
in this case these peppers yielded
almost nothing
but it was a beautiful piece of our a
lot of beautiful cover crops
my take home messages in this uh very
rush presentation today
the problems that we found in year one
of grain senescence from foot traffic or
rust really became an attribute in years
two and three of our research uh because
we moved to incorporating clover and
that clover provided long-term weed
control
those living mulches for us did reduce
onion bulb size
it reduced total pepper yield
and since rye is a grass it attracted
army worms which are a grass pest
to our tomato plops so we had increased
armyworm pressure there
total tomato yield was lower where we
had rye as well
so combined with ryan clover
barley most effective at controlling
yields may or may not
depending on what you're growing
so
[Music]
a few other comments i'll have in my
last couple minutes here
there are benefits that are hard to
quantify when it comes to living mulch
and these are benefits that farmers have
shared with me
one of those is
after a rain
they can go out and harvest whatever
that vegetable crop is and not get
muddy uh that field is going to absorb
water much better and we're obviously
reducing surface erosion that wasn't
one of our research questions here but
we hope that it's one of the benefits of
our work
so we're reducing erosion and we're
improving
harvest or labor conditions
excuse me
we're also improving those harvester
labor conditions this may sound trivial
but it's nicer to kneel down on a living
mulch than it is on bare soil and rocks
and it takes much less of a toll on the
knees of the harvesters if you're
harvesting on your hands and knees so
those are a couple of other benefits
i think the combination of a living
mulch
with a biodegradable plastic film
or degradable plastic film also can fit
into a reduced tillage program which
again was beyond the scope of our
research here
but i like that we're moving towards a
production system where right now the
only plastic in the field is our drip
irrigation tube
so then we could sew a second cover over
crop in those bare row middles if we're
using a degradable
film over top of the vegetable beds
so i'm going to stop there it looks like
i have about four minutes for questions
um
great answering god
excellent presentation any questions for
judd just type them into the chat or
feel free to unmute yourself
i think i see a question from thomas uh
i'll i'll read it out uh
how do you manage the edges of the
plastic that's where the the cover
competes the most he says
yeah great question thomas um
so
it's going to be dependent but in a wet
spring where that
winter winter grainer that is really
growing quickly
we have to
mow it and probably a line trimmer weed
whacker is going to be most effective at
getting those edges you're probably also
going to tie up your or rip up your
plastic a little bit
uh in a drier year or a year where you
have
rust or it's a crop where you have a lot
of foot traffic
it kind of keeps that rye at bay and it
probably never has to be controlled
and the clover in general were not
mowing and i should have mentioned which
species of clover were using we're using
a dutch white clover and we went with a
dutch white clover compared to some
other cobra species because it's
um i would say it has moderate vigor
so it's ideally not competing it
establishes itself well but not quite as
vigorous as
as some of the red clovers or other ones
so dutch white clover was what we looked
at
um judd is is your sense of it that
that there
that there is a solution with using
living mulch to where you have the
living mulch that suppresses weeds but
but doesn't compete with the crop is is
that a
is that a unicorn that we're we're
trying
great question brian um
so farms that are using soluble uh
conventional fertility
might be able to overcome
that competition whatever it is
so i think further research you'd want
we would want to look at is it water or
is it nutrients that the the cover crop
is causing competition and if it's so
then can we respond to it since we have
drip tape there we can provide both we
can provide
additional fertility and additional
water so that might be the unicorn we
just got to figure out which of those it
is
and then which uh which rye was it what
type of rye
yes a cereal rye or um uh winter rye um
right not rye grass so it was a cereal
rye or a winter ride and again we're
applying that in the spring as soon as
our field is fit our plastic is laid but
we don't have any transplant holes yet
thank you brian for the introduction and
uh
it's great to be with you today even if
just online but i'm glad to be able to
share some of a little a tidbit of the
research we
we did on what we're still doing on
cover crop
in veggies especially in in plastic
future
um
so what is our current weed management
complex if we are looking at what's
going on in the wheat science world uh
clearly we need to get more integration
of non-chemical options
um right now i mean we know that for
summer decide um integrating
non-chemical options maybe be
helping us to improve herbicide
performance
we have an increasing issue with
herbicide resistance and it's not just
something which is you know restricted
to soybean or corn that's something that
is affecting us as well in veggies if i
look at new jazz i mean we have soybean
field we have corn field on next street
you have a veggie field on palmer
amaranth will doesn't know the the
boundary between this freedom can really
be a problem in veggies as well um and
if you're looking at uh what went
through the pipeline there beside
pipeline over the last few years i mean
we didn't get any newer besides mode of
action or site of action exactly
for the last 30 years so clearly that's
that's a big stimulus uh for for for
really finding some new uh
non-chemical option um for for for
improving aside control
so how all those cover crop can really
help with weed management well the first
one is really competition direct
competition for light
nutrients water when these cover crops
are growing especially in a dense
stand they can really uh out compete
many wheat species
um when when we are terminating the
cover crop we can really create
depending on the amount of biomass of
cocoa biomass we are able to produce we
can really create a physical barrier
that will really prevent some of these
weeds just to emerge
on the last one is when we are
terminating this cover crop um
especially when we are using herbicide
for terminating cover crop
we may eventually integrate um residual
herbicide at the same time
for extending uh the weight control that
cover crop may be providing uh in in in
crops
so some of the impact some of the cover
crop impact on the wheat life cycle i
really like this picture because it's
it's really showing that cover crops are
impacting every every part of the weed
life um
you can have physical suppression that
will really prevent um you know
seedlings to grow you can have
competition i mentioned that before you
can have allelopathy which is chemical
inhibition i mean some some of the cover
crops that we are working with can
really release some chemicals in the
soil
that can eventually help um suppressing
weed emergence um
cover crop can um host natural enemies
that can
cause some predation on seed on the seed
bunk uh you can modify the
microenvironment and make it less
favorable for wheats to grow and
especially for seeds to to survive over
time so you have a range of different
actions that cover crops can really
have on on on wheat life
that just an experimentation we did a
few years ago in
in northern new jersey actually we're
comparing two different cover crops
we're looking at sodium grass and we're
looking at sun and the crotal area that
john paul i mentioned a little bit
earlier so we we grow this cover crop
for one year on the next year uh we we
follow up with with a prop um we follow
prison with cabbage and what was
interesting to see in this plot was
really looking at the differential
effect of sudan grass on sun and
on every game sugar emergence uh already
i mean it was i was really impressed to
see that sudan grass maybe because of
the a little petty effect was really
helping reducing the density on the
biomass of of getting together the
following year on if you look at the
visual that's that's something that was
taken the next year so one year after
uh terminating the cover crop you can
still see a visual difference in the
number of gaming circuits that are
emerging in this field so
that's something to consider on on you
know sudan grass was really helping us
with suppressing irrigating sugar
emergence
um cover crop biomass we mentioned it
today but that's really very important
topic we tend to consider that cover the
more biomass cover crop biomass we have
the better it is
but not just that it's also looking at
the quality of the biomass that we are
producing especially if you
you we need to look for cover crops that
can really produce
lignin in in the stem because over time
these lignin
you know this lignified stem will
really uh degrade it more slowly
cover crop decomposition that's just a
follow-up with a previous slide but
clearly if you're looking at pure eye
when you know um which is which is
containing a lot of lignin clearly i
mean
you will have a 50 mass reduction
after 170 days if you compare that to uh
to vetch a vet you will be around 53
days on a 50 50 croissant mix will be
around 91 days so clearly the one that
can really provide
longer uh physical uh protection barrier
over the soil for preventing weed
emergence will be a better cover crop
for specifically for weed management
um looking right here at the effect of
planting contamination date of cover
crop and that's the work that stephen
mersky did
at penn state when you were still at
penn state um but clearly i mean if
you're looking at um you know a cover
crop that will be terminated on may 30
so the green the green dots
the planting date is really important
because if you plant it by
september 15
compared to october 15 that will make
ultimately a big difference in terms of
biomass production and we know that this
biomass production is really essential
for for weed control if you're looking
at termination uh something that you're
terminating between may either may 1st
or may 30 and that has been planted at
the same date on october 15 you're
looking at a difference of six thousand
pounds of biomass of cover crop biomass
between these two termination days
between may first on on you know
extending the cover crop up to may 30
will really provide you with with more
biomass that can be useful for wheat
control
so cover crop one some of the challenges
that we have with cover crop for
integrating cover crop in vegetable
production especially in plastic culture
well acceptable recontrolling prostitute
or vegetable system can be extremely
difficult
um that's that's that's one of the
challenges we have with this system too
um on we have very we have fewer heavy
side options that are available in
veggies compared to corn on soybeans so
we the choice of heavy cells that we can
use to to go eventually with the cover
crop uh what not to go with the cover
crop but the type of episode that we
could use for really getting good
control between
the rows of plastic is really limited so
that's another advantage for eventually
considering uh integrating cover crop
into the system
cultivation and on-reading can add
increased fundamental and economic costs
on cover crops seeded in between i mean
square crop seeded in between plastic
walls may provide an additional
re-management tool
we can supplement eventually
herbicide with control by by integrating
cover crop between these plastic rows
we did some experimentation in the past
especially with with university of
maryland
we collaborated with them on a project
with watermelon
um we were just working with sir rye at
this time and we observed that
cry biomass was really peaking
um before the the watermelon
started to to grow
out of the plastic so
that was a good indication that yeah i
mean you when you're getting biomass
accumulation peaking before
the
the watermelon starts going out of the
plastic you're really getting some type
of beneficial effect on weight
management as well something that we
didn't test at this time was really
trying to integrate everything in single
pass can you can you get a single pass
of every side eventually for terminating
the cover crop
controlling the width that i've still
emerged at this time on eventually
including a residual herbicide at this
time so just at the time when you're
terminating your cover crop can you have
all your episodes applied at this time
for for maintaining control over the
rest of the season
so that's what we try to do we started
the experimentation last year
again that's a joint project between new
jazz and maryland
we looked at
evaluating the effect of cover crops
management tactics on which expression
so looking at different type of
[Music]
herbicide
we evaluate cover crops for reducing
episode application on on looking at the
fundamental impact in plastic user
system and we want the system to be also
a good tool for growers for extension to
demonstrate the utility of cover crops
for remanagement in plastic future
systems
so that's that's just the kind of design
that we had last year that we keep
working on in 2022 so we had a
different type of termination so we were
terminating the cover crop either we
spark what cletodine which is strictly
aggressive inside or we had no re we had
no episode at all we tried to just fold
the cover crop
um we had four three different type of
cover crop actually we have we had
survived spring oats on a mix of rye and
oats
um and we had one which where we didn't
have any cover crop at all on the last
one was eventually adding a residual
herbicide at the same time we are
terminating the cover crop so we added
for mesophane on splinter claw or we we
just terminated the cover crop with
either park right clear to them
or rolling it without adding any result
every side
um so we had two different crops uh we i
was working on cucumber here in new
jersey on because
because we have a lot of cucumber
production in the state a watermelon
that's really a specialty of marilyn so
kurt vollmer my colleague working on
this project work with watermelon um our
cover crop proceeded relatively early in
the season uh
but in around mid-april april 2 april 27
um we seeded um our cucumber in june uh
second when the watermelon was
transformed transparently in june 24.
we terminated our cover crop in new
jersey
and on june 24 when the cover crop was
terminated
in july 14 uh for for watermelon in
maryland and definitely harvesting time
is really different between cucumber and
watermelon we have a soda in mid-july
when kurt arrested a watermelon in
september
so when we are looking at some of the
results we we get
we get some i mean for our cover crop
that has been
sealed in spring we get a decent we get
decent biomass accumulation
in new jersey
the great the green bars are the best
cover crop the best biomass producing
cover crop worldwide with almost four
thousand pounds per acre of
of biomass produced
with rye
in in in maryland curd
gets really best uh the best biomass
production with oats with almost 6 000
pounds
per acre of biomass which generally
consider to be the optimal biomass for
really getting some
wheat
weed suppression
if we're looking at smooth speed grid so
we look at different wheat species on
smooth speed weed one was one of the big
weeds that we were
looking for control uh clearly um you
know before integrating any episode in
the mix um
um
we really i mean the we really get some
decent uh control of of a smoothly grid
if you're looking at uh in new jersey if
you're looking at oat rai on old
pressure really the best one the best
mix was mixing oats on rye that's
provided uh clearly a suppression of
pigweed emergence compared to that sense
of cover crop if you're looking at
watermelon
curds get similar result again with
getting a best result
for pigweed suppression
with by mixing oats on rye
on that something that is important
because again i mean i mentioned it
before but
for us in mariner new jersey one of the
big issue is palmer amaranth and we know
that smooth speed we didn't have alma
mount in this field but we know that
spoofs may be maybe a good proxy for
predicting what may happen with spam
amaranth as well
so we are looking at late season
smoothly grid and that was just done in
in
in in maryland and again i mean marilyn
valley they extended their production up
to september 16 when we were done uh by
by mid july so it's almost a two months
difference between the two and clearly
for for this kind of crop where
your production is extended throughout
the end of the season
it's really may be really important to
get to really include a residual
herbicide at the time of uh termination
of the cover crop unclearly for um for
for all the system uh curt managed to so
that including the residual herbicide
was working uh
great for for really maintaining good
control of smooth speed weed up to the
end of the season on addition if you're
adding residual in addition to the cover
crops that's really the system that is
providing you the best type of control
if you're looking at just no cover just
putting the result herbicide you're
still getting more pigweed emerging by
the end of the season compared to the
system where
you have the integration of cover crop
with a resource herbicides
looking at yield clearly i mean
when when we didn't have any cover for
both cucumber and watermelon we really
had significantly reduction
compared to our system with either oats
right on oats and rye um so so really
the cover crop uh really help
tremendously with wheat suppression and
that's why it explained why that is
different in a cucumber and watermelon
[Music]
looking at some of the picture for our
research at in on it was in
on cucumber uh so that was a spring oat
on sir rye mix with new herbicide and it
was in around june 30. so almost two
weeks before we start harvesting the
cucumber on you can really clearly see
that i mean between the rows you don't
you may see uh
one weed at the front but it's before we
don't have any kind of control at this
level because it's not within the plot
but within the plot itself we are
getting really a decent acceptable
recontrol without getting any help aside
one of the challenge that we got with
either rye or oats was really getting
good um
good growth of the cover crop along the
plastic row on that the weakness of the
system is that we
i mean when we seeded the cork crop we
never really get a good
connection in this maybe three four five
inches along the plastic row and that's
where we got a lot of really sleep and
you can see right here you can look at
long squatter this long squatter growing
right along the edge of the plastic uh
can tremendously impact yield because
they are directly competing with the
crop at this level so between in the
center of the raw middle we got
excellent weight control at the edge
where the um either the cover crop was
not
when
was not going well or either we didn't
get enough herbicide
at the edge of the plastic that's where
we got a lot of uh long squatter
development on my last picture is ready
to show you this i mean the type of
wheat pressure we had in this field
where we had no cover prop no herbicide
you can look it's it's amazing i mean i
it was a sea of of uh
of a common long squatter and clearly in
this but that explain why you don't see
any uh i mean why you have such a big
reduction because these plants were
growing taller than i mean they were up
to six feet tall from sparta and they
are shading the ground uh even if you
have plastics they were
you know providing enough shading of the
plastic rose for really preventing any
any crop production so i think it's a
promising you know it's a promising
system trying to integrate both
especially in in situations where we
have challenging weeds such as
amaranth where we know that the clover
crop itself will not be sufficient but i
think it's a nice way of looking at
things by trying to integrate every side
and cover crop together
with that said
if i may have a few minutes for question
brian so i'm here
absolutely that was fantastic thank you
terry yeah if there's any questions uh
you can go ahead and unmute or pop them
into the chat
i saw a question regarding the way we
planted a cover crop between the rows
oh yeah go ahead and actually the way we
did it is that we seeded we manually
seeded all this cover crop which was a
tremendous work to do
we don't have a system yet for sealing
that between the rows but that's some
things that probably need to be
developed over time
the other challenge that we got to was
really rolling rolling the cover crop
between plastic
is is really tricky to do and we were
expecting that the herbicide sprayer
would put enough weight for rolling down
the cover crop that was not the case so
we still have to think about designing a
system where we can roll the crop a
little bit better than what we did last
year
great thank you terry and there's a
couple awesome links
that thomas posted about
uh various features of the different
cover crops i know there's so many it
can be hard to choose which cover crop
is the right for the best situation
and he put some some great links for
that in and steve posted our our youtube
playlist where this presentation and
some of the other
i think all all the other most of the
other expo sessions will be posted as
well
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu